E
UKRAINE'S EFFORTBUILD QUIRE 200
THEY MAYAVE IN THE FIGHT
ECORTERS DENT THE FORMESIDENT C.
TOLD AUTHO
UNABLE TO FIND THE ACTUAL
WHAT'S GOING ON HERE? LIT CANNOL
CANNOT FIND THIS THING,
IDD THE ES
DID HE LOS
DID HE EVE IT DURINGT
WE HE WAS WAVING IT , YOU , CNNR
THIS WAS IN E HE S WAS HAVING A.
AN WAS SAID  BTALKING
ABOUT THIS BATTLE AN
PLAN TO ATTACKRAN.D THE T THE
DOCUMENTS RELATED  ACKMIPROSECUN
RELATED TOS  MEE
JULY OF 2021.
THEY, OF COURSE, THIS AFTER
WHO WASNSIDTHATE WAS BROUGHT B.
SHE WAS PLAYED A RECORDING FRO.
AND THAT'S WHEN PROSECUTORS THEN
ISSUED A SUBPOENA TO THE TRUMP
DOCUMENTS, ANY OF THES
DOCUMENTS TO BE BROUGHT IN.
COTO THE TRUMP LEGAL
, THEY DON'TW THISUMEY
ALSO'TATMEETN,WHETHER THENT WAS.
>> AND ITH THE TRUMP LEGAL
TEAM'S POSITION RIGHT
THEY STILLON K
WHAT'S BEEN TH T
>> KNOW, TY -- AS VE
RI RESPONSES OE COURSE OF TH ING
THOBITICAL
WITCH HUNTE N A TOWN
FOD THE S  KNOWLEDGE O JULY
MEETING.
AND THEY SAYT THEY STILL, OBY,
THE THIS, RSONRE IS THAT
PROSECUTORS THROUGUT
POSSESS CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS
THAT MUST BE RETURNED., THEY'VOG
TO THE TO BE
FOUND IN CONTEMPT.
AND SO FARTHEYTI
DOCUMES  T
RETURNED.
SAYS THAT
HE DOESN'TAVE ANYTHING LEFS POS.
>>PEE IT.
R GEORGE
CONTRIR  "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
OF IT.E NOT SEEN THIWE DON'T KNL
HOW CONCERNING IS IT, THOU,  THE
UNABLE TO FIND IT?
>> WELL, IT IS CDO APPARENTLY
FL
MAR-A-LAGO, PERHAPS, ANDN TO
BEDMINSTERBUT I THINK  TE
DAY, IN TE
NOGO
ON THIS TAPE, EDGED
THAT HE POSSESSED CLASSIED AND
STATOFD WHENS REQUESTED TO GIVEG
ALL BACK AON AND SO FORTH.
ITUSARNARE WE DOT
KNOW WHA EXACTT
WAS.
ITORS WO HER COPIES OF
ACCESS
OUTON CH
TO FIND OUY WHNT MAY HAVE BEEN?L
PEONE ACCESS TO .
HER PRESIDENT IS OTING
OURCE TO ILLEY
DO THA LIKE TOAL THETIONIT, OR Y
FOR ONAL SECURITY.
PEND BILLIONS EN
COLLECTING IIN ORDCT TPE
TH THA
OUR ELECS,
THE PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
, IS SO CAVALIER ABOUT
THOSE  PR MEN
D WOMEN  DANGER.JUSTPOST," THERN
SYRIA AT THE BEHEST OF THE
.
BECAUSE LIVES WE MG DEAL ABOUT ?
STAKE.
OUN ANN SERVIN ARE
AT.E AMERICANS
S COMPROMISETIS
OUT.
>> THE FORMER PRESIDENT WAS
ASKED ABOUT THIS DOCUMENT AND
E RECORDING ACKNOWLEDGHE DOCUME.
EVERYTHING I D RIGHT. PRESIDE
LUDICROUS ANSWER, JUSTAYING HE
ING ABT IT.
THERE'S ALA RECOY ASK SOMEBODY
ABOUT IT IF HE WANTETOR
THAT QUESTION.
HODO OF THISE
THE FORMER PRESIDENT'S
AS IT RELATES TO THE SPECIAL
COUNSEL'S INVESTIGATION?
WILL BED HE MATTS  DISPUTEEVEN I
THE SEARCH. VN  FBI  GETRAN
CEN
HEEXECUTED THED FOUND E IVING TC
DOCUMENTS.T KNOW THAT STATEMENTS
MAKE IT ANY WORSE FOR
TH MAKE IT
LOCATE AT LIKE THIORN ITS INTEL
EVEN A NOTION THAT A FORMER
PRESIDENT WOULD BE WAVIN
LIKE THIS, HOW DO
IMPAC
WILLINGNESS TO WOR AND ARU.S.?
>>L, IT RE ERODES AN
NE DRELEASED INFORMATION MPLE, R
RUSSIAN FOREIGN MINISTER,
RUN AMBASSAD, THAT MAY
HAVENTAIL
SEQUENCCOOM ISRAEL.
THEY HAVE TO SAY, IS THE
INFORMATION WE'RE GIVING TO
UNITTA BE D?
BECAWET SK FRONT
AMBASSADORS, O MILITARY, L AT R
WITH THE GT OF C ITOE REALLY
AND THAT CLEARLY IS NOT THE CASE
T NS
TIME AND TIME AIN.
RG
YUT THEE LINE
DOIT
ANYTHING, BUT WHAT DO YOU THINK
SPECIAL COUNSEL'S STIGATION?
>> I THINK THEIM
GENERALLY IS JUS
THE FACT THAT WEW SO MUCH
NOW ABOUTHE INVESTIGPENS IESE A
THWED BY THE
JURY.CE DEPARTMENT OR THI, NT TH
AND NOW YOU'REER WHO KNOW, AND W
ALL SHARED I
IS N SAYIN
ANYTHING THAIS BEING
CONTCTY SOME OTHER
D LOTS OLE KNOW A LOABOUIS
INVESTIGATION,
WE'RE SEEING THIS
INFORMATHAT'S INTERE>> WHICH ME
IOY DO
AND WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT IT, YOT
T
RUSHING  F POLITICAL
PU RUSHING TO
ELECTION SEASON.ICATIO -- HAVINE
NEXT YEAR.G IAL TOO
SUMMER OR NEXT YEAR,
T CASE
SOONER RATHER THANAT.
ARHE CAMPAIG
RE GETTHAT WAY YOU INSUL
RGE THAT YOU'RE
DOING IT F PIT
BUT I THINK WHEN THIS INDICTMENT
COT,G  BA